what is the German beer Purity law
it's celebrating its 500th birthday and
is the first German law governing food
back then beer was a staple in people's
diets a kind of liquid bread and it was
women who brewed the beer a brewing VAT
was often part of a woman's dowry nuns
and monks were allowed to drink beer
especially during periods of fasting in
that regulation of 1516 the Duke of
Bavaria said beer may only contain
barley hops and water he had a point
some Brewers added poisonous mushrooms
to the mix or belladonna which made some
people sick yeast joined the party by
accident it seems when it blew over from
nearby bakeries it was eventually added
to the official list of permitted
ingredients the love of beer inspires
inventiveness the engineer Carl von
Linde
developed a cooling system to enable
fermentation in warm weather that was a
precondition for mass production German
Brewers have left their mark around the
world mr. Busch and his partner mr.
Anheuser pioneered industrial brewing in
the United States their company has
grown into the world's biggest brewer
now known as a bee InBev it boasts 200
brands Germany has a large number of
breweries large and small 1388 at the
last count
some of them experiment with unusual
ingredients such as chocolate oranges or
cilantro these be rebels say the purity
law is outdated and a drag on creativity
the traditionalists say that with the
hundred varieties of hops forty kinds of
malt and two hundred strains of yeast
there is plenty of scope for innovation
the guardians of purity have poured some
concoctions down the drain fighting over
beer goes way back especially when a few
too many pints have been downed well
then Cheers